plus de 30000 personnes ont été évacuées
de l'île de Rhodes en Grèce voilà 7
jours que des feu gigantesques
grignotent s'est-il de l'archipel du
dodécanisme l'opération d'évacuation des
habitants et des touristes et la plus
importante jamais organisées en Grèce
[Musique]
le bilan faisait état de plus de 40 000
hectares brûlés en 7 jours dont 9000 ce
week-end et depuis dimanche plus de 70
départs de feu ont eu lieu en Grèce dont
la plupart sont incontrôlés certains
pilotes français de Canadair se sont
rendus en renfort sur l'île grecque nous
avons vu les flammes qui montaient à 5
ou 6 mètres de haut sur plusieurs
centaines de mètres voire kilomètre de
long ce ne sont pas forcément des feux
exceptionnels mais on sait que c'est
quelque chose qui va durer longtemps
avec des températures stagnant vers les
40 degrés le pays connaît l'une des plus
longues canicules de ces dernières
années en Grèce le manque les moyens et
l'absence de prévention en vue de la
saison des feux font depuis quelques
jours polémique le gouvernement est
pointé du doigt sur le manque de moyens
d'infrastructures et de préparation des
autorités face à ces événements qui
semblaient prévisibles avec le
changement climatique et la période
estivale est touristique n'arrange pas
la situation tant les zones touchées par
les incendies étaient prisées par les
touristes en 2002 7 fois plus de surface
qu'une année ordinaire a brûlé en France
et trois fois plus en Europe le Maghreb
était également concerné alors que le
mercure a frôlé les 50 degrés lundi en
Tunisie au moins 34 personnes dont 10
militaires ont péri dans de violences
incendies survenues dans le nord-est de
l'Algérie dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi
[Musique]